SENATOR TUCKER CARLSON COMING UP
NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IMAGINE HOW IT MUST FEEL TO BE
TO BE BETO O'ROURKE, RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, VICE PRESIDENT, YOU
ARE RUNNING ANYWAY.
YOU ARE GIVING SPEECH AFTER
SPEECH EVERY DAY.
CHILDREN ARE THE FUTURE TODAY
THE FIRST DAY OF THE REST OF
YOUR LIFE.
INSPIRING STUFF LIKE THAT, DEEP
STUFF LIKE THAT AND THERE IS A
PHYSICAL COMPONENT TO THE JOB
TOO.
READING YOUR SKATEBOARD FOR THE
CAMERA TAKING GOD KNOWS HOW MANY
CELL FEES FIRST SNAPCHAT AND
INSTAGRAM.
IT IS NOT AN EASY GIG.
ONE MOMENT YOU DISCOVER THAT
YOUR ONE TRUE LEFT THE AMERICAN
NEWS MEDIA HAVE CALLED IT OFF
AND LEFT YOU FOR A YOUNGER,
HARDER CANDIDATE.
WITH A PACK OF CIGARETTES AND
NEVER CAME HOME.
SPLIT WITH SOME GUY FROM INDIANA
THAT YOU CANNOT PRONOUNCE HIS
NAME.
>> THERE HE WAS YESTERDAY, FRONT
AND CENTER, NOW THIRD IN THE
POLLS WITH A SPEECH THAT MANY
HAVE SAID OUR HISTORIC.
>> INSPIRATIONAL SO FAR AND
SOMETHING THEY WANT TO.
>> AN APPEAL FOR A LOT OF
REASONS.
HE IS A VETERAN, OPENLY, HE IS
FROM GHANA, HONEST AND SPEAKS
FROM THE HEART AND A LOT ABOUT
EMPATHY HERE.
YOU ARE A CONCERT PIANIST AND
SPEAKING NORWEGIAN BECAUSE YOU
WANT US TO READ A BOOK.
>> A REAL RENAISSANCE MAN.
SMARTER, IT IS SO SMART TO TRY
TO CHANNEL OBAMA.
THE SECOND COMING OF OBAMA, WE
WILL SEE ABOUT THAT.
TO THIS POINT, YOUNG, FRESH,
POSITIVE CHANGE.
>> THIS GUY --
CHICKEN SOUP FOR MY SOUL.
>> Tucker: CHICKEN SOUP FOR MY
SOUL.
EVEN NEWS STANDARD MEDIA A NEW
LEVEL OF COMMITMENT.
THEY DON'T JUST WANT TO VOTE FOR
THIS GUY BUT CONSUME HIM LIKE A
HEARTY STEW.
EVERY LAST DROP OF BOOTED JUDGE,
THEY ARE ALL IN.
GLOBE WHAT IS GOING ON HERE
EXACTLY?
WHO IS THIS GUY?
A LOT OF LIBERALS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
WHY WOULD THE 37-YEAR-OLD MAYOR
OF SOME MIDWESTERN CITY, NO
OFFENSE BUT THAT IS WHAT IT IS
MY WAY WITH THAT GUY STAND OUT?
WHY IS HE MORE IMPRESSIVE THEN
COME I DON'T KNOW, CORY BOOKER
OR FORMER GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR HICKENLOOPER WERE
11,000 PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS --
DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
AT THIS MOMENT?
WHY IS THIS GUY BETTER THAN
THEM?
THAT IS EIGHT TOUGH QUESTION
ACTUALLY.
WE CHECKED AND NOBODY KNOWS.
BOOTED JUDGE HIMSELF, HIS
WEBSITE GIVES A BIO AND TELLS
YOU HOW YOUNG HE IS, AND IT SAYS
PRETTY MUCH NOTHING ABOUT WHAT
POLICIES HE MIGHT SUPPORT.
IT IS -- IT IS NOT AN ACCIDENT
BUT POLICY POINTS WE CANNOT TALK
ALL THE TIME.
IF DEMOCRATS FIGURE OUT HOW TO
TELL A BETTER STORY ABOUT THE
PRINCIPLES.
AND ACTUALLY THAT IS NOT A CRAZY
POINT.
STORYTELLING DOES MATTER.
BUT FIRST, YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHAT
YOUR STORY IS.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
PRINCIPLES ARE.
AND SUDDENLY NEITHER PARTY KNOWS
THIS.
THEY ARE NOT SURE WHAT THEY
STAND FOR IT.
THAT IS REALLY WHY THINGS SEEM
SO BIZARRE RIGHT NOW IN THIS
COUNTRY POLITICALLY WHETHER SO
CHAOTIC.
THE CONFUSION ESPECIALLY ON THE
LEFT, WE HAVE TO SAY BECAUSE
WHEN THE ONLY PRINCIPLE IS
GAINING POWER, WHILE, YOU ARE
OUT OF LUCK.
YOU WANT TO LIVE EIGHT AND
PEOPLE LIKE BERNIE SANDERS WHO
SEEM LIKE THEY ARE ACTING ON
PRINCIPLE BUT JUST THE OPPOSITE.
HERE IS ONE EXAMPLE
BERNIE SANDERS TOOK FIRE FROM
THE LEFT THINK TANK PROGRESS.
THE IRONY AND IT'S REAL, THAT
BERNIE SANDERS BECAME A
MILLIONAIRE BY WRITING A BOOK
ABOUT HOW MILLIONAIRES ARE EVIL.
SANDERS DIDN'T LIKE THAT
CRITICISM.
LAST NIGHT HE DELIVERED THIS
RESPONSE TO IT.
LISTEN.
>> YOU RISCH -- RAISE THE ISSUE
I'M A MILLIONAIRE BUT WE HAD $56
I'M A MILLIONAIRE BUT WE HAD $5,
I'M A MILLIONAIRE BUT WE HAD $50
INCOME AND THAT'S A LOT OF
MONEY.
ENOUGH MONEY IN MY CASE, MY
WIFE'S CASE, A BOOK THAT I WROTE
PRETTY GOOD BOOK.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO READ IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THE BESTSELLERS SOLD ALL OVER
THE WORLD SO IF ANYONE THINKS
THAT I SHOULD APOLOGIZE FOR
WRITING A BEST-SELLING BOOK, I'M
SORRY, I'M NOT GOING TO DO IT.
>> Tucker: THE QUESTION IS NOT
SHOULD YOU BE ALLOWED TO WRITE A
BOOK BUT THE QUESTION IS SHOULD
YOU BE A MILLIONAIRE DOING IT.
BERNIE SAYS SHALL, IF YOU WANT
TO BECOME A MILLIONAIRE WRITE YU
TO BECOME A MILLIONAIRE WRITE YR
OWN BEST SELLER.
SO BERNIE'S SOLUTION IS WHAT?
WITH ME NOW, ENTREPRENEURSHIP
LIKE JACK CAMP AND RONALD REAGAN
AND THEY WERE NOT EMBARRASSED
ABOUT IT AND NEITHER WERE THEY.
LET'S CALL NOT CALL IT
SOCIALISM, BERNIE MAY THINK IT
IS BUT MORE LIKELY HE DOESN'T
THINK ABOUT MUCH ABOUT ANYTHING.
HE IS NOT CAPABLE OF IT OR
DOESN'T CARE TO OR WHATEVER.
HOW ELSE WOULD YOU EXPLAIN THIS?
SANDERS COMPLETELY BAFFLED OR
THINK McCALLUM ASKED HIM A
SIMPLE QUESTION THE DASH WHERE
SHOULD THEY BE KEPT EXACTLY?
>> THE OVERFLOW WE HAVE NO
CAPACITY FOR, WHERE DO YOU THINK
THEY SHOULD GO?
WE NEED REAL COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION?
WE DON'T NEED AND LET ME SAY
THIS CLEARLY, WE DON'T NEED TO
DEMONIZE IMMIGRANTS.
THAT, WE DON'T NEED.
>> BUT ANSWER MY QUESTION WHICH
IS RIGHT NOW, IF YOU WERE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
WE HAVE OVERFLOWING FACILITIES.
THEY NEED TO GO SOMEWHERE
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN ASYLUMS.
WHERE WOULD YOU PUT THEM?
>> WHAT ABOUT BUILDING PROPER
FACILITIES FOR THEM RIGHT NOW.
>> WHERE?
>> ON THE BORDER.
>> SO THE PEOPLE ON THE BORDER
SHOULD HAVE MORE FACILITIES IN
THEIR STATES BUT SANCTUARY
CITIES, ACCEPTING PEOPLE SHOULD
NOT?
THIS IS A POLITICAL ACT.
>> KNOW IT'S NOT.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT A REAL
QUESTION FROM US AS
BERNIE SANDERS BUT KEEP IN MIND
SANDERS THE FRONT RUNNER IN THE
DEMOCRATIC RACE FOR THE NATION
NOW AND IMPRESSIVE AT LEAST A
MAN OF PRINCIPLE LIKE VERY
SMART, REALLY.
SO WHERE SHOULD THEY BE KEPT?
HE BASICALLY SAID, NOBODY SHOULD
BE DENIED ENTRANCE AT THE BORDER
OKAY, SO WHERE SHOULD THEY'S
STATE.
SHUT UP THAT IS NOT A REAL
QUESTION.
PAST IMMIGRATION REFORM.
HE WENT IMMEDIATELY TO TALKING
POINTS.
IT IS NOT IMPRESSIVE BUT
BUFFOONISH.
THE LOGICAL INCOHERENCE IS
PRACTICALLY A CAMPAIGN PLANK.
FOR EXAMPLE DEMOCRATS TELLING
AMERICANS SPEND TOO MANY PEOPLE
TO JAIL AND THEY MAY BE RIGHT
ABOUT THAT.
WE SEND A LOT OF PEOPLE TO JAIL.
THOUSANDS OF DRUG DEALERS OUT OF
JAIL EVEN THOUGH WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE WORST DRUG
EPIDEMIC IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THEY EVEN GOT THE WHITE HOUSE TO
SIGN ON TO THAT ISSUE, YOU MAY
HAVE NOTICED SO IT IS HAPPENING
THAT LEGISLATION PASSED AND
SIGNED.
EVEN THOUSANDS OF CRIMINALS
STREAM OUT TO FREEDOM AND TO
VOTING WHICH IS ALWAYS THE
POINT, AT LEAST ONE DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE ERIC
SWALWELL SAID A NEW CLASS OF
PEOPLE WE NEED TO SEND BACK TO
PRISON.
MASK INCARCERATION ON A SCALE.
WATCH THIS.
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION FOR ASSAULT
WEAPONS, WHAT IS THE PUNISHMENT
FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAND HIM
THEIR GUNS, DO THEY GO TO JAIL?
BUT I ALSO OFFER ALTERNATIVE A
HUNTING CLUB OR SHOOTING RANGE.
BUT THE GREATEST THREAT TO THE
SECOND AMENDMENT IS DOING
NOTHING.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS NOT AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHTER]
YEAH, THE GREATEST THREAT TO THE
SECOND AMENDMENT IS NOT SENDING
MILLIONS OF LAW ABIDING
AMERICANS TO PRISON AFTER THEY
HAVE BEEN RECLASSIFIED AS FELONS
OVERNIGHT.
THAT IS THE REAL THREAT.
SO HOW IS THIS GOING TO WORK
EXACTLY?
HOW DOES WALL WILL PLAN TO SEIZE
THE WEAPONS AND ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE AND WHO WILL FIGHT ON HIS
SIDE DURING THE CIVIL WAR
THAT WILL RESULT FROM THIS, WE
HAVE NO IDEA AND NEITHER DOES
ERIC SWALLOW WELL, HE THINKS
THE LEFT WANTS TO HEAR.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE DOING
ON EVERY TOPIC, THE GREEN NEW
DEAL THE MOST IMPORTANT THING,
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE BEACHES
OF NORMANDY AND WINNING WAR OR
TWO, THE MAN ON THE MOON, NEIL
ARMSTRONG.
SO IT'S IN THE GREEN NEW DEAL,
NOBODY KNOWS THEY ARE MAKING IT
UP AS THEY GO ALONG, IMPEACH
TRUMP.
IT MUST BE DONE.
AND THE CHARACTER TAKING A BREAK
FROM PRIVATE EQUITY OR WHATEVER
HE DOES.
AND VOTE HIS WIFE TO IMPEACHING
TRUMP.
WHAT ARE THE CHARGES?
THEY DON'T KNOW.
THEY DON'T HAVE AN IDEA AND THEY
CAN'T TELL YOU.
DEMOCRATS DON'T KNOW WHO IS
LEAVING THEIR PARTY RIGHT NOW.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ SAYS
SHE'S LEAVING THE PARTY,
NANCY PELOSI SCOFFS PASSIVELY
AGGRESSIVELY IN RESPONSE TO
THAT.
>> SHE LIKES TO MINIMIZE THE
CONFLICTS WITHIN HER CAUCUS
BETWEEN MODERATE AND THE
PROGRESSIVES.
WHO HAVE THESE WINGS, AOC AND
HER GROUP ON ONE SIDE.
>> Tucker: COMMITS LIKE FIVE
PEOPLE.
AND BY THE WAY THE DIVIDE IS NOT
BETWEEN THE MODERATES IN THE
PROGRESSIVES, THERE IS NOTHING
MODERATE ABOUT NANCY PELOSI.
THERE'S NOTHING PROGRESSIVE
ABOUT ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
HERE IS THE REAL DIVISION.
IT IS BETWEEN EQUALITY WHICH IS
THE TRADITIONAL LEGITIMATE --
AGENDA OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE AND THE NEW
WING OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WHICH NANCY PELOSI BIGGER THAN
FIVE PEOPLE BUT THE IDENTITY
POLITICS WING OF THE PARTY.
THE IDENTITY POLITICS IS THE
OPPOSITE OF -- BUT PRECLUDES
EQUALITY.
THEY MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE.
IDENTITY POLITICS, NOT EQUAL.
SOME ARE MUCH BETTER THAN
OTHERS.
SOME MUST BE DESTROYED.
THAT IS NOT EQUALITY.
THAT IS PERMANENT WAR.
SO THAT IS WHAT IS TAKING THE
PLACE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUAL.
YOU CAN SEE IT EVEN IN THE
PERSONAL BEHAVIOR OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES FOR
PRESIDENT.
BETO O'ROURKE TURNS OUT
ONE-THIRD OF 1% OF HIS TOTAL
INCOME TO CHARITY LAST YEAR.
HE'S A A RICH GUY TOO.
KAMALA HARRIS, 1.4% TO CHARITY.
SO WHY ARE THESE PEOPLE NOT
BEING CALLED OUT ON THIS?
THEY WANT TO GIVE -- RUN THE
COUNTRY BUT THEY DON'T -- THEY
ARE AGAINST WHITE PRIVILEGE SO
IT IS ENOUGH.
EXCEPT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
THIS IS NOT A SATISFYING STYLE
OF POLITICS BUT ACTUALLY IT
DOESN'T IMPROVE ANYONE'S LIFE.
IT IS NOT WORKING.
THE DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT EVEN THOUGH STANDING
ON THE SIDELINES NO IT'S NOT
WORKING.
THEY WILL LOSE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP UNLESS THEY
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF ACTUAL PEOPLE.
OTHERWISE, THE CONTRADICTIONS IN
THE PARTY WILL BECOME